i love jojo like my whole entire life
i want to be her one day
i've always wanted to be a pop star this
is my dream
i have the ability to be a star
i want to be famous
[Applause]
hi
we are gonna make you guys the next
phenomenon there's something missing in
the world of music
and that is kids pop original music
so we're making a pop group and i want
kids that have something special about
them
i'm cool and i'm swag i feel like i'm a
beast and i'm
awesomely good we're costumed we're
highlighted we're glitz and we're ready
to go she's been undefeated for two
years and she's only been dancing three
years kenley please take it out of your
foot
one two step in time to make a perfect
combination what it takes to be a pop
star is unimaginable five six seven
eight this eight week audition is not
just singing
it's not just dancing
it's everything
we brought 11 kids here that might have
it now we got to see you delivered i
feel confident and i'm going to crush it
so you can perform that was incredible
we want them to be triple threats tatum
you got the talent other girls have all
confidence and not the talent
and i know what they are looking for
they won't cast two girls that look so
similar
she's seeing kai as a threat i'm not
scared of you angie i'm not intimidated
you either it's not about who went home
but it's about who stayed
it's almost like when you watch a movie
and like the bad guy wins
go out there and give the best
performance of your lives your costumes
are huge your music is huge your
performance is huge you need to be huge
[ __ ] big family jump around jungle rap
last week i was at the bottom now i'm at
the top we're not used to being at the
bottom this is not easy if you don't
kill it you're going home y'all don't
understand how bad she wants this i'm
scared and i just want her to be in this
group
you are the very first member
[Music]
you